this is a Wendover productions video
made possible by Squarespace get your
domain before it's gone with Squarespace
moving the President of the United
States from one location to another is a
logistical nightmare that happens every
single day the American president is one
of the most powerful persons in the
world and there is no time when the
president is more exposed than when
they're in transport two of the four
successful assassinations of American
presidents where when they were
traveling Garfield and Kennedy for that
reason the Secret Service devotes an
enormous amount of resources to ensuring
the president gets from one place to
another safely the presidential
motorcade is perhaps the most impressive
method of transportation it includes up
to 40 or 50 vehicles and over 100 people
let's take a look at some footage of a
motorcade this is a lead car or in this
case motorcycle as the name suggests its
job is to lead the motorcade but it's
not actually the first vehicle what we
don't see here is the route car which
would have come through about five
minutes before the lead car the route
car is always followed by about 20 or 30
motorcycles which play the essential
role of clearing the route of cars when
driving on a highway
they'll speed ahead and close exits so
that no cars can come on the highway
although they have to use a different
technique in cities when driving in DC
where other drivers are used to frequent
motorcade to the motorcycles often drive
in a V pattern pushing cars to the side
to clear the way for the motorcade this
leads to a disruption of only about two
or three minutes outside of DC drivers
are less used to motorcade
so the motorcycles will typically
completely block off the intersecting
streets to create one continuous clear
path to the president the entire first
section of the motorcade isn't actually
run by the Secret Service it's run by
the local police jurisdiction of
wherever the president is the fewer
Secret Service cars and individuals
needed for motorcades the better since
both the cars and agents need to travel
to wherever the president is visiting in
advance which is of course incredibly
expensive the next part of the motorcade
is what's known as the secure package
it's the essential core to the motorcade
because it's a group of cars that
directly secures the president in case
of attack
this group of cars can detach from the
rest of the motorcade and function as an
independent unit the most important car
in the secure package is the president's
limo but one can never be sure which one
that is
because there are always two limos these
two limos are identical they even have
the same license plate that way an
attacker can for example have a spotter
tell them which car the president left
there or jannat the limos themselves are
no ordinary limos they weigh between
15,000 and 20,000 pounds and are built
on a modified truck bed the entire car
is bulletproof
including five inch thick bulletproof
windows the only window that can open is
the driver's window reportedly so they
can pay tolls the entire car is
hermetically sealed to protect the
president from a chemical attack and on
board our rocket-powered grenades
night-vision optics a cure gas cannon
pump-action shotguns bottled oxygen and
two pints of the president's blood type
this car leading the secure package the
United States Secret Service electronic
countermeasures surburban it leaves the
secure package because its purpose is to
jam any remote activated explosives
along the route these two tall antennas
do that by sending out a huge range of
radio frequencies that would block any
palm activation signal the two domes on
top of the car are most likely what's
known as electronic warfare sensors
they're essentially radars that can
detect when a rocket-propelled grenade
or anti-tank guided missile is launched
when it detects a launch the car would
most likely activate a number of smoke
grenades spread out throughout the
secure package which would help throw
off the grenade or missile but of course
this is all classified
so that speculation this car is a
control car it carries the most
essential staff like the president's
military aide and doctor in the event of
an attack
they're both essential to the president
so they break off with the secure
package these last two cars are both
filled with Secret Service agents the
closer one is called the halfback it
carries the president's personal Secret
Service detail these are the agents that
are on the president's person at all
times
the second one is a cat car the counter
assault team you can always identify
these cars since they are the ones with
a back window open that's because the
agents are sitting in rear-facing seats
with automatic weapons ready to respond
to threats
while it's hard to see you can just make
out the counter-assault team in this car
in black battle dress uniforms and the
president Secret Service detail in this
car in potent time in the event of an
attack the president's Secret Service
details is in charge of shielding and
evacuating the president while the
counter-assault team would generally
stay and repel the attack these vans
following the secure package are full of
the press pool reporting on the
president this car is called the ID car
and the Secret Service agents inside are
the ones that communicate with outside
counter surveillance teams that
proactively identify any threat to the
motorcade this black truck is the
hazardous materials mitigation unit it
has equipment and personnel who can
identify and respond to chemical nuclear
or biological attacks on the motorcade
continuing on you can see more press
fans these motorcycles are speeding by
the side because now that the motorcade
has passed the exit that they were
blocking off they are going to the front
of the motorcade to block off more exits
this car is called the roadrunner it has
a number of antenna on the top to act as
a mobile communication center it
connects the motorcade to the outside
world through satellite and Internet
communication systems following this is
a generic ambulance in case of injury to
any person in the motorcade like the
police officers at the front of the
motorcade this ambulance just comes from
the local fire department of wherever
the president is this last kicker
service car is the support car which
carries more Secret Service agents and
the essential staff members lastly these
three police cars are there to make sure
that now that the exits are open again
no car speeds up and enters the
motorcade from behind it's important to
note that this is just a standard
motorcade configuration it often changes
based on the environment when President
Obama visited Iraq in 2009 for example
his motorcade looked like this military
Humvees led a convoy of identical
Suburbans one of which carried the
president on top of the cars were more
powerful versions of the anti RPG
antenna found on the normal electronic
countermeasures suburban so motorcades
are incredibly efficient it's been
reported that motorcades have made the
trip between LaGuardia Airport and the
Waldorf Astoria Hotel in Manhattan in 8
to 10 minutes that's a 10 mile drive
that takes a normal driver 20
five to thirty minutes although the
safest motorcade is still no motorcade
since it's the most exposed the
president ever is so the Secret Service
will typically only use motorcades for
trips up to 30 minutes long motorcades
are also incredibly logistical e
difficult and expensive so whenever
possible the president will travel on
marine one marine one isn't actually the
name of a specific helicopter it's
rather the callsign use by any
helicopter with the president aboard the
Marine Corps operates 35 total
helicopters of a few different types as
marine ones which might seem like
overkill but these helicopters are also
often used to transport the vice
president when they're known as marine
two or government VIPs while marine one
is occasionally used to transport the
president from point to point it's most
frequent mission is to bring the
president from the White House to
Andrews Air Force Base
the president's planes are based at
Andrews Air Force Base so this 12 mile
trip is how the president starts and
finishes any long distance trip much
like the president's limo marine one
never flies alone right after takeoff
it's meant by as many as five other
identical helicopters which shuffle
positions in flight to throw off
potential attackers Air Force One is
also not a particular aircraft but
rather the callsign used whenever the
president is aboard an Air Force
aircraft typically the role is served by
one of two modified Boeing 747 to give
you a sense of how efficient this entire
transport system is let's climb a trip
from the White House to the UN
headquarters in New York the 12-mile
flight to Andrews Air Force Base takes
about eight minutes on marine one then
upon arrival the president steps on
board Air Force One the president is
always the last person to step on Air
Force One
so the second he's there the door closes
and the aircraft taxis for takeoff that
means there's about five minutes between
touchdown of marine one and takeoff of
Air Force One from there it's about a
30-minute flight to JFK Airport in New
York followed by a seven-minute trip on
marine one to downtown Manhattan hello
for than a six minute motorcade of FDR
drive to the United Nations that means
that if everything goes perfectly
including transfer times it will take
almost exactly one hour for the
president
go from stepping out of the White House
to stepping inside the United Nations
and what is the cost of this hour-long
trip
well it's public information that Air
Force one costs an estimated two hundred
and six thousand three hundred and
thirty seven dollars per flight hours so
this half hour flight cost 103 thousand
one hundred and sixty nine dollars but
of course we need to include marine one
marine one by itself is actually fairly
inexpensive to operate well we don't
know it's exact operating cost one of
the helicopters often used as marine one
is the sikorsky uh-60 blackhawk which
costs two thousand one hundred and
ninety nine dollars per flight hour but
of course marine one always flies in
formation with up to five other
helicopters per helicopter a quarter
hour of flight time costs five hundred
and thirty dollars or three thousand one
hundred and eighty dollars total
the motorcades cost for the short trip
is fairly minuscule so we'll leave it
out for simplicity but the helicopters
and cars need to get to new york and
this is done by loading them up on a c5
galaxy cargo plane which costs one
hundred thousand nine hundred and
forty-one dollars per flight hour or
fifty thousand four hundred and seventy
one dollars for the half-hour-long trip
to new york altogether that's one
hundred and fifty six thousand eight
hundred and twenty dollars for the
hour-long trip to new york for two
thousand six hundred and fourteen
dollars per minute and keep in mind that
the president needs to travel back to
ultimately transportation of the
president cost the American taxpayer
about three hundred and fifty million
dollars per year roughly one quarter of
the one point four billion dollar yearly
White House budget this is certainly a
steep price but many would argue that
it's a small price to pay to keep the
most powerful person in the world safe
this video was brought to you by
Squarespace as you probably know I'm a
big fan of Squarespace I've used them
for years for a few different websites
including the official Wendover
production site not only do they have
the best website builder out there
they're also the simplest and fastest
company to buy a domain through to prove
that I decided to buy a new domain
Wendover productions net as you can see
here it took me exactly 60 seconds and
twenty dollars and now you can reach my
site at Wendover productions calm and
net if you ever want to start a YouTube
channel a business
anything you should register a domain
now I never had a problem because I
bought Wendover productions calm through
Squarespace when the channel is still
small but there are tons of horror
stories of people who start a business
become successful and then have to pay
thousands to buy the domain from someone
who snatches it up before they do most
of the domains on Squarespace are only
twenty dollars that's the cost of one
third of a second on Air Force One and
by using the links Squarespace comm
slash Wendover and the code Wendover
you'll get 10% off your first order and
help support the channel other than that
you can support Wendover productions at
patreon.com slash Wendover productions
follow me on twitter at Wendover pro
watch my last video on every state in
the u.s. here check out my fan moderated
subreddit here and most of all subscribe
to this channel to receive all my future
videos right when they come out thanks
again for watching and I'll see you in
two weeks for another Wendover
productions video